pop
[Musique]
et m
waouh
[Musique]
qui expédiait ma bicyclette
comment je fais pour la voir une
bicyclette mais regardez voilà le
bulletin
[Musique]
oh
vous avez vu ce qu'il y à votre voiture
quoi si jamais comme ça qu'est ce qu'il
ya le numéro n'est pas le même à l'avant
qu'à l'arrière
non vous ne le saviez pas ne restez pas
là il est un vélo et voilà tu as le plus
loin à les fissures constatées fiche le
camp et gac la tombe et l'eau je vais
vous dire qu'est-ce qu'elle a son numéro
n'est pas le même à l'avant qu'à
l'arrière voit les voir on s'est trompé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez vu non vous n'avez pas
remarqué l avant 3976 et à l'arrière
3796 c'est pas possible tu es toujours
l'inscrire sur mon carnet pour quoi
faire
star enseignements
[Musique]
vous êtes tombés vous avez eu un
accident
qu'est ce que tu viens fait à paris si
toi les en vacances c'est ma route
mais alors si j'étais out alors pourquoi
tu t'arrêtes tu as vous aider puis vous
êtes en travers du chemin dire
l'empêchent de passer moi bah alors
pourquoi les affaires non tu peux pas de
vous seulement comme vous étiez par
terre à l'ehpad histoire est tu va
pêcher le carré vite te pas encore parti
oui oui c'est moi qui vais t'aider tu
vas voir et puis surtout ne revient pas
paru si elle tue peu d'histoire un tu as
compris pour pas me chercher des
histoires moi parce que
[Musique]
charles auguste
et
[Applaudissements]
bye
les chameaux guide comprend pas j'ai
compris la lampe est allumée
qu'est ce que tu fais là dedans non
mais
[Musique]
bonjour bastien et comment étaient venus
par le train je suis descendu à la gare
de la longue
puis j'ai traversé la forêt à bicyclette
en bon
qu'est ce que tu faisais blot photos
d'un appareil
j'ai l'appareil mais je m'en sers pas
qu'est ce que tu as encore trouvé entre
je vais t'expliquer
laboratoire de charles auguste et est
maintenant très bien arrangé il manquait
rien il y avait toutes sortes
d'appareils en état de marche et
d'autres qu'il n'avait pas encore
réparées il y avait aussi des objets
d'art qui l'avaient descendue du grenier
[Musique]
mais le plus formidable de tous c'était
son placard à malice au début j'ai été
pris je croyais que c'était une glace
comme une autre sur la porte
et puis je me suis mise à l'intérieur et
je me suis aperçu qu'on pouvait voir au
travers comme si c'était une vitre on
appelle ça une glace sans tain ça permet
de voir sans être vu
en somme il s'est installé dans le
bâtiment dans la famille de charles
auguste on avait toujours appelé seul
bâtiment battu mais au fond du jardin
[Musique]
ça devait servir d'écurie et puis après
on y avait garé des voitures même qu'il
en reste lui qui servait plus à personne
depuis longtemps parce qu'il ne marchait
plus c'était une vieille bagnole et puis
il y avait aussi une ancienne cave mais
fallait passer par la trappe pour y
descendre
c'était pas commode alors personne n'y
allait jamais j'ai raconté à charles
auguste ce qui m'était arrivé et tout de
suite il a tout est clair tableau
[Musique]
tu veux relire première question l'homme
est il un voleur deuxième question qui
contenait la boîte
troisième question pourquoi la voiture
avait-elle de numéros différents
il faudrait se demander si l'homme de la
voiture connaissez l'homme du viaduc
qu'est ce que tu en penses et toi je ne
sais pas il faut réfléchir faudrait
comprendre
réfléchissons
[Musique]
voyons la bicyclette était bien une
bicyclette de dames
oui avec des routes 65,65 modèle ancien
l'homme était grand fort une vraie brute
avec de grandes mains et des gros doigts
mais gros doigts qui cherchaient à
prendre de petits objets et de l'endroit
tu te souviens on pour ça je peux pas me
tromper
on dit cette pile sous le viaduc
exactement
bon eh bien pour répondre à la première
question une seule méthode méthodes
appliquées qu est ce que c est la
méthode appliquée recherches sur le
terrain examen systématique avec ça
c'est là qu'il est tombé dessus je peux
pas me tromper ou encore les traces
tu es fou non qui cherche pas de cette
façon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on aurait peut-être mieux fait s'occuper
de la voiture
dis donc si on allait à la gare de la
lande pour voir voir quoi je sais pas
moi ya peut-être quelque chose à voir
[Musique]
je trouve quelque chose pas encore va
passer toute la terre tu le vaux sur
login quoi at on dit la marche est là
c'est une voie ferrée bah oui mais on
peut marcher le long d'une voie ferrée
bien sûr une bête ya pas de sangliers
dans la forêt dans la forêt peut-être
mais pas sur le viaduc puis de quoi au
far west
y'a pas de souliers aux parois jemelle
tu as trouvé quelque chose et que
l'apparence métalliques les pinces
enveloppe ou
le caillou tu as compris ce poids est
donc bien t-il ce caillou du ciel
regarde y'a un truc à lui c'est le trou
pour l'échappement des eaux et des
cailloux c'est de là qu'il est tombé je
suis sûr qu on nous regardait on monte
allons-y à deux on risque rien
je mêle enveloppe au fond du tamis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez pas on a écarté les plaques
de ciment
tu vois j'en étais sûr qu elle qu'elle
était là qui nous surveillaient
qui ce peut-être
oh
méfie toi
s'ils veulent après galilée désaffecté
au oui ça se voit ça va il sont drogués
qu'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant on
va d'abord goûté paraison ses fins je
connais l'endroit où nous sommes
tranquilles à la maison du roy
[Musique]
pourquoi qu'on appelle ça la notion du
roi la cause de françois 1er
il habite à deux jours il paraît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelle torture prison personne n'en
doute déçus si la peur leurs droits
[Musique]
sinon cerveau gauche par le quotidien de
trois co fondée par son chef qui
voisinent gêna pas pour voir comment
trouver quelque chose ça non je crois
que c'est important vers un seul
laboratoire
c'était une idée pragma métalliques
c'est peut-être cela ça m'étonnerait
tu entendu oui c'est là-haut quelqu'un
vous écoute c'est par ici
tu crois je serais curieux de savoir où
aboutit ce vieux tuyaux de cheminer sur
le toit plutôt à les pages bouge pas je
vais aller voir tu vas rester ici tu vas
jouer l'harmonica dans clio pour que le
mr perrut commence à jouer d'exposition
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais là qu'elle vient
chercher où ça quelqu'un lanvin j'ai vu
la partie fermée par le grand d'elle
[Musique]
regardes quoi les tartines
tartine et chocolat
c'est une preuve ça oui ça c'est une
preuve
quelqu'un nous observe
[Musique]
c'est une preuve ça ah oui ça c'est une
preuve quelqu'un nous observe
à mon avis il est sorti vers un sketch
où ça il n'y a que la pelouse ne doit
pas être loin un homme qui vole de la
nourriture commence par manger parce
qu'il a faim tu crois qu'il a faim il a
pris nos tartines
bon allez viens on va faire une
inspection autour de la maison de
naissance voilà ici
l'amdi viaduc pis fiche de nous qu'est
ce que vous voulez vous me cherchez
pourquoi ben on savait pas répondre non
j'habitais dans cette maison j'habite ou
cheveux on n'a personne j'aime pas corde
autour de moi et puis je veux savoir
pourquoi vous cherchez vous mais pour
vous donner nos tartines
vous avez l'air d'avoir faim le punk
anglais cèdent pas tout le monde dont et
les cailloux condensats qui sont-ils je
peux pas répondre et vous inquiéter sur
le viaduc 10 qui c'est celui là là là
c'est mon cousin germain
vous savez on n'a rien contre vous mais
alors pourquoi tu es revenu avec lui
alors depuis qu'est ce que tu cherches
un aparté un mois des champignons des
gens à des champignons c'est et que vous
faites partie de la société la quelle
société
oui on s'arrache que le divin et nous on
ne comprend pas et je vous assure qu'on
veut vous aider
pourquoi vous vous cachez à cause des
gendarmes
bon c'est pas les gendarmes qui me font
peur j'ai rien à voir avec les gendarmes
morts d'ailleurs pourquoi c'est une
société secrète
c'est des gens à histoires et je veux
pas d'histoires moi j'ai compris de
toute façon vous ne craignez rien il ya
tellement de cachette dans la forêt le
plus difficile c'est de trouver à manger
on peut vous rendre service des fois
pour aujourd'hui ça ira c'est plutôt
pour demain il vous reste rien non vous
avez tout prix déjeuner sur l'herbe on
aura coulé si vous voulez on peut être
là demain midi sur la pelouse
on aura aussi une bouteille de vin c'est
entendu mais vous venez tout seul et
vous le dites à personne
n'ayez pas peur à demain tadic en même
temps là apportez moi une feuille de
papier c'est pour écrire on faire un
paquet c'est pour la boîte aux toiles au
tu veux tout savoir c'est promis on vous
la portera à demain
sabri objet métallique d'une année que
la vice de forme irrégulière
c'est en quoi pour l'instant je n'en
sais rien encore 0,1 écrit longueur 5 mm
d'épaisseur évaluation approximative un
dixième de millimètre calcul du volume
longueur x largeur x épaisseur ne trompe
pas dans les virgules
connaissant le poids et le volume d'un
objet je pourrais calculer sa densité
facteur indispensable en identification
d'accord a connu
[Musique]
il ya là quelque chose de tout à fait
particulier pour quoi nous avons affaire
à un corps de très forte densité
l'accord très lourd si tu préfères plus
lourd qu'elle mercure sensiblement plus
lourd qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
s'agit d'un corps tout à fait inconnu
il faut considérer nos mesures comme
très approximative la balance manque de
précision je ne suis pas sûr de
l'épaisseur mais chiffres sont inexacts
vraisemblablement alors le corps est
peut-être connu connu mais rares je
pense au radium
pourquoi simple supposition le radium se
transporte avec d'énormes précautions
dans un container qu'est ce que c'est un
container une sorte de boîte métallique
c'est tout nouveau et métalliques je te
le dis pourquoi cet homme aurait-il
transporter du radium sur sa bicyclette
et parce que c'est un voleur il l'a
privé où laure et il brille on trouve
pas du radium comme cela il n'existe que
dans les laboratoires ou les instituts
il n'y en a que deux mille cinq cents
grammes dans le monde
ce pourrait être quoi alors particules
métalliques brillantes de fortes
densités on peut pas dire autre chose ça
nous avance pas beaucoup
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire encore
l'obscurité couple courant
ça continue à briller luminescence
padoue phénomènes de luminescence
tudeau charles-auguste c'est du radium
la bronche pas pourquoi cause des
radiations bus que c'est du radium
comment elle est située
[Musique]
le radium ça vaut cher une fortune c'est
une bonne raison pour le valais à mon
avis l'homme du viaduc était un
intermédiaire stupide dans une
organisation très compliqué tout de même
il doit bien savoir où il a pris le
paquet il faut absolument le faire
parler il ya qu elle faire manger il
parlera je m'occupe du déjeuner si tu
veux je vais prendre certaines
précautions en ce qui concerne ce petit
objet quelles précautions protection
contre les rayons gamma mur de planck 15
cm d'épaisseur
[Musique]
pousse la porte je me le rouge au pardon
à bien ses plans
je donnais la carapace le plus
d'épaisseur possible il peut y avoir des
fuites faudrait pouvoir vérifier la
protection avec un compteur geiger
tu crois que c'est encore dangereux je
dois prendre mes responsabilités
demain nous portons la marmite ordinaire
c'est plus prudent est pour l'instant où
on va je n'ai sur l'herbe à la maison du
roy
t'as rien oublié je crois pas le tire
bouchon
j'ai mon couteau ça doit être bon j'ai
prévu pour 4 parce que lui je le compte
tours 2 et la feuille de papier
d'emballage
c'est prévu tout est prévu
[Musique]
oui
et oh
j'ai appelé ça répond pas y a personne
quelle heure est il
2h30 ne viendra plus ça alors et
pourtant il avait dit oui puis c'était
bon qu'est ce qu'on fait rien rien à
faire c'est manquer ça j'ai eu tort de
lui parler de la boîte
c'était une erreur mais certainement
autre chose
certainement si on déjeunait il ya
quelque chose qui l'a empêché de venir
sur moi on va pas manger ta faim au oui
alors j'ai faim allez à table ata jourt
une bouteille se passe quelque chose
mais quoi
viens avec moi on va faire une
perquisition
où ça la maison a son secret à nous de
le découvrir
[Musique]
ensemble ou chacun de son côté
ensemble je préfère moi aussi je préfère
me ou commence comme ça au rez de
chaussée
non c'est à l'état de nous écouter c'est
à la fenêtre de l'étagé s'est montrée
donc s'étaler tâches qu'on doit trouver
quelque chose mais tu es déjà ronde et
hier je n'ai fait que passer aujourd'hui
on va fouiller dans tous les coins audi
dans ouest france le premier cherche pas
à l'abri
[Musique]
on
c'était là qu'il nous écouter
c'est là qu'il habitait voilà son lit
puis sa table de nuit et être ainsi
comme ça la tête inclinée
il écoutait tentant de quelque chose le
bruit de la mer qu'est ce que c'est que
ça
attends avec précaution
[Applaudissements]
l'acteur jaunâtre ça se mange avec de la
crème
c'est très bon bon je résume l'homme du
viaduc habitent cette chambre
quelquefois en tout cas et il se nourrit
de champignons qu'il mange cru c'est
pour ça qu'il a toujours faim un homme
dans la force de l'âge ne peut pas se
nourrir de champignons et champignons
été fraîchement accueillie le repas
était préparé et l'homme a disparu
on a voulu l'empêcher de parler je crois
que c'est la société secrète
j'en ai peur il faut le constater la
société secrète a fait disparaître
l'homme du viaduc
comment ont-ils su que nous avions
rendez-vous et sous cachets partout les
écoutes
cet homme du viaduc que je veux savoir
ce qu'il est devenu mais comment faire
tenter notre chance
les lactaires pouces sous les chênes là
où il ya des chaînes il ya des lactaires
le grand bleu forêt pour sortir de
l'impasse il ne faut rien négliger
ou alors on abandonne
oded on regarde un peu ce qui est écrit
vol de cobalt actif dans une usine de
seine-maritime
on a dérobé avant-hier un élément
radioactif dans une usine
cet élément du cobalt 60 qui pèse
environ 3 mg était enfermée dans un
container en plomb de 3 kg servais des
opérations de contrôle d'une usine qui
fabrique des bouteilles de gaz
le cobalt est un métal dur d'un blanc
argenté qui ressemble au faire lorsqu'on
introduit dans le coeur d'une pile
atomique il devient radioactifs c'est
alors le cobalt 60
quel que soit son degré de radioactivité
le cobalt 60
peut être enveloppé dans un emballage de
plomb très épais alors on s'y est pas
trompé nous on s'est pas trompé j'ai
bien fait de confectionner une marmite
pas le moment d'abandonner bien où ça
veut dire des champignons sous les
chênes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un acteur jaunâtre oui il y en a
d'autres endroits m'intéresse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya quelqu'un d'aussi bouge pas
et peut-être endormi c'est pas naturel
oh
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur vous avez peut-être
l'heure les quatre heures et demie merci
monsieur merci monsieur ces sauvages par
ici il faut aimer la solitude c'est rare
de rencontrer quelqu'un oui c'est rare
ou alors il faut se donner rendez vous
pourquoi vous dites ça comme ça pour
rien on aurait dit que vous attendiez
mois nous j'attends personnes vous
bougez pas je me repose et j'ai beaucoup
cherché cherché quoi des champignons et
c'est fatigant
on en sait quelque chose et puis il faut
s'y connaître vous y connaissez vous
monsieur c'est bien vous êtes peut-être
professeurs oui je suis professeur
allais les enfants allez vous promener
au revoir dites-nous est ce qu'on peut
trouver par ici des mygales vous voyez
ce que je veux dire
ah oui oui j'en ai vu il y en a et c'est
la saison merci au revoir monsieur
il a l'air bien pressé maintenant qu'est
ce que tu en penses d'un menteur
pourquoi n'est pas professeur il ne
connaît rien aux champignons
ah oui les médias ne sont pas des
champignons mais des araignées
d'amérique aux dits doux mais alors
qu'est ce qu'il faisait là j'attends
mais il attendait l'homme du viaduc ne
peux pas l'affirmer mais il attendait
quelqu'un c'est certain et coûte quoi tu
entends rien bouge pas écoute tu entends
maintenant on dirait une pendule le
tic-tac d'un mouvement d'horlogerie
[Musique]
le tic-tac d'un mouvement d'horlogerie
le type qu'on a rencontrés il a
peut-être installé une bombe il installe
une bombe il s'assied dessus et il
attend je fais pas et qu'est ce que
c'est alors
ça vient de la terre il doit y avoir une
caverne reste ici je vais descendre voir
non t'appellerai confie toi ton choix
rien je ne suis pas fou
voilà l'explication c'était arrivé le
matin j'y avais pensé ma peau ça peut
servir un réveil matin dans la forêt à
savoir l'heure
audi dont je reconnais c'est la
bicyclette de l'homme du viaduc
alors ici aussi on est chez lui
c'est sa salle à manger mais il a sa
chambre à la maison du roy et sa salle à
manger dans la forêt pas très pratique
une feuille de papier d'emballage tout
neuf ma parole elles sont insérées
paquet croit pas intéressant c'est du
feu aussi avec quoi avec du bois mort
dans une forêt n'en manque pas il
voulait aussi du papier pour allumer il
allume sont faits avec des vieux papiers
tu reconnais reconnais quoi parce que ce
n'est pas un morceau du papier
d'emballage qui enveloppait le container
ou cherchait rien
ici regarde et quelque chose d'écrit
suisse avec un s à la fin ça prend pas
des sla suisse ya qu une suisse sur le
premier il y
elle l e et sur l'autre 23e place moi le
premier
ce papier d'emballage avec fragments
inscriptions encre violette ou cherchent
encore inutile plutôt calmes et
tu viens ça m'a déjà oui restons pas là
on peut nous surprendre
il donc la primeur on pourrait peut-être
à chauffer pour voir s'il n'ya rien
d'inscrit oui importe là on l'examinera
au laboratoire elle vient
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu en penses à temps que
je réfléchisse faut justement pas
réfléchi plus ferme les yeux et tu les
ouvrir à quand je te le dirai à ce
moment là tu me diras si ces deux
containers ou si ce n'est pas le
container tu as compris je veux bien me
sign on regarde pas
regardent peut-être ces malheureuses que
tu manques d'observation mais tu montres
un paquet tout fait la boîte elle est
ouverte et puis tout en disant ça n'a
aucun rapport
postulat je suppose a priori la
reconstitution exacte
mettons en place les fragments de
papiers brûlés que j'ai pu recueillir
mois d'observation mais toi tu fait
joujou j'emploie les méthodes modernes
ça et rien c'est la même chose
nous verrons suisse avec un s ça fait
drôle
résonant le container était enveloppée
d'un papier prêts à être expédiés à une
certaine adresse et on expédie pas un
container de cobalt 60 par la poste ni
par le train ou alors les expéditeurs
ignore le contenu du paquet va alors
demander c'est malin c'est facile
à calais alors rendez-vous dû être à
l'image qu'est ce que ça veut dire l
être à l'image tu sais l'arbre avec une
sainte vierge dans une guérite je
connais après et c'est là qu'ils ont
rendez vous cherchez pas je t'attends
demain près dû être à l'image avec le
paquet maintenant c'est fini de rire je
peux plus me taire
signée jugé très intéressant mais
vois-tu trouvais ça dans la caverne avec
une méthode à moi c'est aussi fort que
de fabriquer de fausses boîtes de vieux
bouts de bois un container robot alors
on y va
tu parles seulement demain c'était
peut-être aujourd'hui on ira toute façon
j'ai la première lettre du premier nom
de la sphère d'appui pas là dessus c'est
pas dangereux
elle met au moins 20 kg de plomb ça peut
fuir les radiations ou par an je sais où
on va placer la marmite au moulin de
pierre un endroit désert est bien dégagé
ou ce pas trop loin le moulin en pierre
non pourquoi parce que c'est lourd puis
les points n'est-il pas faim
la voiture la voiture que j'ai vu à la
gare de la londe la personne à
l'intérieur
dirait qu'elle est abandonné
on y va en avoir l'air je promène
elle a toujours ses faux numéro pas de
réflexion tétouan
la personne
et personne
si vous de quelle semaine
le message était signé g descelers cette
fois on a le nom entier sont en panne
on va voir
regarde on enlevait les fils de bougies
la tête du distributeur pas de danger
qu'on laval
la vraie plaque de la voiture
chc la suisse ge genève la suisse encore
la suisse comme sur le papier
d'emballage
on est sur la bonne piste oui
intéressant qu'est ce qu'on fait on se
cache pour atteindre inutile on avec
total mais la plaque dans le coffre
nous considérons cette voiture comme
abandonné dans la forêt prévenu la
gendarmerie
où va la gendarmerie n'ont pas alerté la
gendarmerie par téléphone au carrefour
du pont victoria café et pourquoi on
sait ça pas bon parce que c'est notre
devoir et ensuite parce que la requête
officielle peut nous aider à avoir des
renseignements c'est pas bête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en victoire vite c'est plus à peine de
téléphoner au contraire c'est le moment
il faut des barrages
produits dont il a été vite qui conduit
drôlement ils nous écoutent encore mieux
il a entendu ce qu'on a dit là bas
la preuve il est ici on entre quand même
puisque nous attend
bonjour monsieur on voudrait téléphoné
pour un maxi l'un des constatations
vous avez une cabine a déjà quelques uns
pour atteindre assez ou
on cherche quelque chose
merci ah bon
vous m'avez bien compris faux numéros
voiture grise immatriculée 3976 les
vrais numéros sont dans la malle arrière
communiqué du signalement de la voiture
je ne voudrais pas avoir d'ennuis avec
les gendarmes
je suis en mission oui on vous a prévenu
bureau international je vais d'ailleurs
pas ses lois pour certains enseignements
merci beaucoup
mes respects mon commandant
je connais toi aussi je vous connais
c'est un camarade c'est mon cousin
germain très bien commissaire plantevin
police fédérale suisse si vous permettez
on va parler un peu de coeur nous et
bien d'ailleurs se plaît je veux
m'expliquer tout de suite au sujet de
claques l'erreur dont les numéros
c'est une maladresse je me suis trompé
dans les fausses plaques
vous avez remarqué tout de suite toi il
a d'observation et chez voire jamais
téléphoné à la gendarmerie pour ne pas
avoir d'ennuis avec mes collègues
français au cas où la comprenez pourquoi
voyager vous avec de fausses plaques d
rien de plus simple
en france une voiture suisse ça sera moi
et j'ai besoin de passer inaperçu on
comprenait très bien pour savoir hier 3
[Applaudissements]
m'occupe d'une enquête difficile
graphique d'or entre la suisse et la
belgique en passant par la france
c'est la route vous comprenez dans la
forêt je cherchais quelqu'un j'ai
l'impression que vous aimez jouer les
détectives comme ça lui surtout il a
l'air malin et puis là d'observation je
suis sûr qu'il a découvert pas mal de
choses
alors tu va m'aider si vous permettez
j'ai quelque chose à dire tout à l'heure
à chacun son tour et j écoute je vais
raconter tout ce que tu sais comme ça
deviendra je vous dis que je ne sais
rien alors là tu vas un peu fort toi tu
as une tête de pioche seulement méfie
toi j'ai ma voiture au bord de la route
alors je te fais monter je t'emmène où
ça monsieur le commissaire à la
gendarmerie
je peux le faire c'est parfaitement
légal vous comprenez bon alors si vous
voulez rentrer chez vous ce soir je ne
vous conseille pas de jouer au plus
malin
dites moi ce que vous savez il faut
parler bastoche le commissaire plantevin
a raison mais qu'est ce qu'on sait bien
tu le sais bien qu'on sait rien tu vas
te taire oui ne vous occupez pas de lui
je sais tout va si vite
ici on peut y entendre la personne à la
forêt non plus il y avait personne
et pourtant ce métier là alors où j'ai
attaqué à vous montrer a pas que un
paquet comment s'attaquer enfin une
espèce de boîte entourée de papier lourd
passé
tu as ouvert à non on l'a trouvé ce
n'était pas à nous alors ça tout de
suite non ça marche pas quoi ça marche
pas dans la journée faut attendre le
soir j'ai rien dit à ma famille on est
quatorze il faut attendre que tout ce
monde là soit couché c'est l'ont compris
adresse rue haute la dernière maison et
un jardin où il ya une porte en planches
c'est la fleur minutes je vous attendrai
avec la boîte justement voulait la
remettre à la police
d'accord au revoir monsieur le
commissaire
c'est pas un vrai commissaire je le sais
bien
le coup de téléphone à la gendarmerie
c'était du bluff je vérifier pourquoi
que tu veux à parler pour le faire
marcher le rendez vous de ce soir à
minuit
c'est un piège
[Musique]
le piège que nous avons imaginé consiste
à enfermer le faux commissaire dans la
cave
quand il sera notre prisonnier nous
aviserons sur la conduite à tenir
il faut bien entendu qu'ils descendent à
la cave de sa propre volonté
ce qui importe donc c'est de piqué sa
curiosité cette trappe ouverte ne
manquera pas mais auparavant nous
essaierons de le photographier sans
qu'ils le sachent à travers la glace
sans tain je l'inviterai pour cela à
s'asseoir dans ce fauteuil bien éclairé
par le projecteur s'il pouvait être dans
l'attitude de bastien
ce serait parfait
[Musique]
à 00h14 le chrono rupteur allumera
automatiquement lumière l'extérieur et
je sortirai sous prétexte de
vérification laissant le faux
commissaire seul dans le laboratoire
[Musique]
dissimulés derrière la glace sans tain
bastian profitera pour prendre un ou
plusieurs clichés du bonhomme moi
j'attendrais dehors prêt à couper la
corde qui tient la trappe ouverte
latente pourrait être plus ou moins
longue
elle dépendra de l'hésitation du faux
commissaire devant la trappe et de son
désir de trouver rapidement la boîte
qu'il est venu chercher
bastien transmettra le signal au moment
voulu
en allumant la lampe rouge que je
n'aurais pas quitté des yeux je ferai
alors le geste qui nous donnera un
prison
[Musique]
00h20 d'un placard